se a efe de x igual a gdx dividido entre
x cuadrada menos x menos 6 donde ge x es
un polinomio cual de las siguientes
opciones es una posible gráfica de ye
igual a efe de x y aquí nos dan cuatro
opciones de gráficas verdad que en donde
alguna de ellas debería corresponder a
esta función
efe y aquí nos indican justamente que
las líneas punteadas son asiento estás
verdad indican asiento estás entonces te
invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta o bien si comienzas a tener
problemas cuando lo estamos resolviendo
juntos pues pon pausa al vídeo en
cualquier momento o también si comienzas
por si comienzas a sentirte por ejemplo
inspirado para para terminar de
resolverlo es importante tratar de
adentrarse en el problema en lugar de
sólo verme resolverlo
muy bien ahora vamos a resolverlo todos
juntos así que podemos notar que en
realidad no sabemos mucho sobre nuestra
función f verdad solo sabemos que el
numerador es un polinomio pero pero
además nos dan un denominador verdad así
que este denominador es x cuadrada menos
x menos 6 y podríamos pensar por ejemplo
en algunos valores interesantes que toma
este denominador en particular por
ejemplo podríamos pensar en que valores
de x se se hará 0 el denominador verdad
en que valores de x se anula el
denominador y para hacerlo podemos
tratar de factorizar la verdad
simplemente por ejemplo aquí vemos que
tenemos un coeficiente menos 1 y tenemos
que pensar en dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 6 pero
sumados me den menos 1 verdad entonces
rápidamente uno puede ver que menos 3
por 2 es menos seis y menos tres más 2
en efecto nos da menos una verdad
entonces podríamos reescribir a fx de la
siguiente forma de hecho lo hace un
poquito más abajo
un poquito más abajo fx se puede
escribir en el denominador como x menos
3 por x más 2 y el numerador seguiría
siendo gx verdad entonces ahí lo tenemos
podríamos ver que justamente en x igual
a 3 o en x igual a menos 2 es justamente
cuando se anula el denominador voy a
escribirlo así como que tenemos cero en
denominador
no me
muy bien entonces en este caso que
podríamos tener bueno podríamos tener
asín totales verticales verdad en estos
puntos o bien podríamos tener una
discontinuidad removible verdad pero
para que haya una discontinuidad
removible entonces gx tendría que verse
de la siguiente forma x menos tres que
multiplica algún algún otro factor
verdad de esta forma como que podríamos
cancelar x menos 3 verdad podríamos
cancelar el factor de arriba con el
factor de abajo y entonces tendríamos
una discontinuidad removible verdad
entonces bueno eso sería por ejemplo una
opción de la otra opción es que que no
se anulará en x igual a 3 verdad en cuyo
caso no podríamos factorizar x menos 3 y
entonces está digamos en el punto x
igual a 3 tendríamos una a sin total
vertical así que bueno ahora sí vamos a
analizar qué es lo que ocurre con
nuestras cuatro opciones vamos a ver qué
pasa con la opción
aquí podemos ver en la opción a que
tenemos una cinta vertical en x igual a
menos 2 aquí en x igual a menos 2 hay un
asiento está vertical lo cual está bien
con lo que hemos obtenido verdad debe
debe haber alguna de esas dos opciones
ya sea una cinta vertical o una
discontinuidad removible en x igual a
menos 2 sin embargo si nos pueda y si
nos colocamos en x igual a 3 podemos ver
que la función está definida en ese
punto así que esto no coincide con el
hecho de que deberíamos ver una cinta
vertical o una discontinuidad removible
así que nuestra opción a no es una
opción viable vamos a ver qué ocurre con
la opción b aquí podemos ver que tenemos
una sin tota vertical en x igual a menos
2 y tenemos una cinta está vertical en x
igual a 4 pero esto eso está bien en x
igual a menos 2 pero no está bien en el
otro punto verdad porque en el otro
punto debería ser
x igual a 3 y de hecho podemos ver que
en x igual a 3 aquí sí está definida
otra vez la función y no debería ser así
verdad entonces esta segunda opción
tampoco es viable vamos a ver qué ocurre
con la opción c aquí podemos ver que en
x igual a menos 2 tenemos una asiento
está vertical y además en x igual a 3
tenemos una sin una discontinuidad
removible verdad entonces esto es esto
es bastante compatible con lo que
teníamos anteriormente verdad justamente
habíamos dicho que debían existir a
síntomas verticales o discontinuidades
removibles en tres y en menos dos verdad
entonces la opción c es un buen un buen
candidato de hecho es consistente con lo
que habíamos dicho de la expresión de fx
verdad porque en este caso f x sería
bueno lo que tenemos en el denominador
vemos el denominador kutz
tenemos el denominador que es x menos 3
por x 2 pero como tenemos una
discontinuidad removible en 3 el
numerador se debería ver como x menos 3
por otro polinomio muy bien entonces
bueno eso es la expresión para la
función f
vamos a ver qué pasa con la última
opción que es la opción de aquí podemos
ver que tenemos una a sin tota vertical
en menos 1 y una sin tota vertical en 6
entonces nuevamente ésta no es
compatible con la información que
teníamos de nuestra función
fx así que para concluir podemos estar
seguros de que la opción correcta es la
opción c